so my friends and family they thought
that the interest in policy is actually
pretty weird you know you don't usually
have 13 14 year old kids
debating congressional elections but I
think that wonkiness really served me
well when I was starting this company
and whatnot hi my name is Tim Wong I
currently serve as the founder and CEO
fiscal ax I am 23 years old so fiscal
note what we do is we're a real-time
legal analytics platform so that means
that we aggregate legislation
regulations and court cases from around
the United States and increasingly from
around the world and then leverage
natural language processing and
artificial intelligence to be able to
come up interesting analytics around
those laws themselves so we can predict
the outcomes of legislation we can
actually predict the the directionality
of regulators and actually start to
predict the outcomes of court case than
litigation so I started off in politics
and was sort of at the center of
politics and technology my entire life
started off in the Obama campaign back
in 2008 doing a lot of data analysis
work and field organizing work and
actually served in elected office when I
was seventeen trying to use data
analytics for public and public
education so my junior year in college I
got tapped head of a policy organization
called the nya and one of the biggest
problems that we had was actually trying
to follow what was going on across the
country in Obamacare and immigration
reform and telegram reform and the
traditional way getting this information
is actually from attorneys paying a ton
of money to K Street lobbyists and I
thought well this is actually really
dumb problem from a computational
perspective and so you know tried to
look at this problem and solve it from
there
the key ingredient for our company
success has always been Sir this
intersection between politics and
technology and so I think this sort of
the the new age of technology is
actually not just looking at technology
for technology's sake but actually
applying it to specific industries that
really haven't seen that innovation
before and personally I think the legal
and political industries are actually
when the last industries to see
significant technological change and
that's one of the things that's really
driving us as a sort of mission
statement